it's that time
[Music]
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive
[__] pilot to Bombardier uncle
Joey here never fear it's Monday
you balsa wash your muscle you [__]
[__] shined you've powdered
everything you're ready to [__] stab
my [__]
what's happening you bad [__]
your uncle Joey here trying to put the
pieces together cloudy gloomy day but it
don't matter it's the sunshine and your
nutsack that matters you understand me
when you see people you look em in the
eye you smile [__] tremendous it was
my [__] skewer I had a great time in
Sacramento great [__] shows great
people great food you know how we'd do
it next week Pittsburgh Primanti
Brothers the [__] Roberto Clemente
statue it's time to [__] light
yourself on fire you understand me but
enough with the chitty-chat a spark
there soldier about the children
it pays to smoke the best I got free
[__] today I got this death on two legs
tremendous the [__] me up since I got
off the plane yes dad take two
[__] naps understand [__]
monday [__] the plan is laid
out you know what you got to do you've
been bullshitting yourself the too
[__] long it's time to polish that
[__] helmet Vaseline you a soul and
get out there you Vaseline yes or not
cuz you ever get [__] but because you
don't want to be squeaking when you walk
inside anyway that's it this is it you
smoked a number you make your plan you
write your goals and you attack the day
I got your beatings coming my way
tonight I jujitsu I got a podcast later
o'clock hopefully you'll be there
[__] there's mr. squirrel are you
doing mr. squirrel he's alright this but
he's got a big [__] family gotta help
him out cheer him up I'm gonna do some
more smoking one of the [__] savages
up in Sacramento showed up but we've he
should have put some [__] hash dust
forget about his this [__] Donald
Trump's [__] ex-girlfriend smoke
we're going beat the late [__] my
night it's Monday what could either go
with your life well in you sound like
Karen's gonna talk to you [__] [__]
finds about 119 a way to go to Europe
and walk around with a backpack or suck
my dick some of this to put some of this
oh yeah some [__] does never do my
[__] goombas brought me look at me
look at that that's a Puerto Rican
hamburger then we're gonna put some more
on here on top like this get ready for
[__] voyage [__] the yellow submarine
and the [__] magical mystery tour
this is uncle Joey [__] the voyage of
debt not the moustache
chicken cutlets and [__] Waveland
how you go [__] say that
attention you're in America America
that's right did you [__]
forget every day you're the best [__]
country in the world you walk around
talking [__] with your [__] iPhones
looking around and I can't wait to tell
you never go to Bangladesh suck my dick
go get banged in the [__] ass or walk
around these American cities
look at these [__] salute the
flag - they understand me we forget from
time to time you see a flag new [__]
turn around you stand at attention that
you saw a dead [__] say what
I'm an American [__] you know what
that means that do what the [__] I want
that's what that means gotta sir please
but enough with the chitty-chat enjoy
English Martin and [__] soldier what
I gotta go back inside I he
[Music]
all deep pockets Lewis well it was like
a [__] fart on my belly why it stays
farmed [__] the fog got that economic
Greg Lisa [__] hang leave again he
really lives over here the [__] feel
the effects
[Music]
here the plane pilot to Bombardier pilot
apartment did come in pilot to
Bombardier come in I'm being cut suckers
all right you want to drop something
drop it if not thank you [__] hair
somewhere else
anyway enough with that [__] each eyes
gonna be a good week [__] when you
get out of bed today your two feet hit
the floor you gotta look up and say God
thank you forgive me another day the
[__] be a savage - bang somebody's
head off the [__] wall and get my
dick sucked to get back what belongs to
me understanding when you're born they
put a fate in front of you but it
dissipates over the years you got to go
back and get that [__] it's what
belongs to you and God wants you to
[__] tunnel sucking dick the dude I
was about [__] no but you gotta go get
it it's not that I'm just gonna [__]
hand it to you then I'm running a
[__] charity out there
I don't give a [__] I go get that
[__] every day
somebody's got your lunchbox just
sitting there talking to me they can't
wait to know did [__] Coachella what
the [__] you talking about [__]
Coachella [__] joke the [__] everybody
go get what's yours it's [__] Monday
I understand there's a [__] about these
humps I can't wait to go jump up and
down the Jersey Shore the [__] wrong
you're an adult understand you're an
adult I'm smoking on the ball or you
guys tap it out on them enjoy I don't
nobody tap in here today it's Monday if
you tap now you'll be sucking [__]
dick holes by [__] Thursday yeah I'm
pissed I feel it the special take that
shot was still shooting Chicago Rose me
whenever rose month October 1517 my
special guest Bob lulling is she
understand that's how we [__] roll
[__] October 15th
Rose not two shows
the flying jewel be there I'll be ready
to [__] rock let's put some more
gorilla biscuit dust on him and let's
call it Danny got a mother [__] got
things to do people to see
let's do this let's do this don't do
this that's it real quick good boy you
[__] light whatever the [__] you
don't you got bombs taylors the woman of
the year
Julia Roberts feet in jail that's it we
have a little tape Dante we got together
tonight's your lucky [__] night
a p.m. the church I was [__]
happening now is full [__] affect me
understand me
who's the guest none of your [__]
business natural natural it's a surprise
TuneIn be there or be [__] it's where's
my best bottle of thinking I we [__]
MOOCs I love you [__] have a
great day go out there remember delay
them the world is theirs
Mamma Mia being a liar mamma memoir on
board
I love you guys 8 o'clock tonight stay
black have a [__] great Daniel listen
listen David antibodies able to wake up
and [__] apologize you understand me
I love you [__] stay black